I mean this is dangerous you don't even
know we're doing yet there's darts yeah
I'm gonna have to throw something
there's people back then mm-hmm do you
guys value your lives what's up I'm
Kevin and today aren't challenging my
coworkers to see who can hit a
bull's-eye with their eyes closed
closest to the center gets $100
it's the closed eye bull's eye challenge
close eye challenge cheering yes
welcome to the closed eye bull's eye
challenge challenge so the last time you
did the perfect circle challenge I did
great you did well thank you you did say
that you brought dishonor on your family
I did I'm I'm back to do it again here's
how it works
have you played darts before I have are
you good at darts yes but using about
four beers deep depends how many beers
they have I'm usually not sober when I
play darts are you drunk right now
no Kelsey know your secrets a room it's
Tuesday are you sober now
yes why does everybody say they don't
drink on TV are you all just alcoholics
is it mean okay I'm not gonna judge what
I want you to do is I want you to grab
one of the darts over there toes up to
the line here the rules all you have to
do is take that dart and throw a
bull's-eye oh you took your glasses off
Oh need them right this is regulation
distance and that's regulation height I
don't trust you about trusty oh wow
okay cool you only get one shot let me
get one shot okay it's just like the
perfect circle challenge you only got
one shot there yeah well if it doesn't
land on the board yeah you get to try
again
whoa whoever gets closest it's $100 cash
money yeah does that change that changes
everything
I'm touched I don't touch they're really
gonna touch close eye bull's eye
challenge how you feeling I'm sweating I
really am are you I just started
sweating yeah so what's your strategy
there is no strategy
there's never strategy okay hold winging
it I love it I believe in you
[Music]
you're gonna have to go it's okay okay
all right
[Music]
whoa that's amazing
holy first line worst one mom you are
the man to beat
what's the secret just elbow straight
okay pointing at the dartboard okay and
you don't move it it's just like they
literally have to hit the bull's eye in
order to beat you didn't hit the bar at
all didn't it before it at all I'm not
good [ __ ] up let's oh okay it's the foot
here's the thing you're gonna have to
hit the board at some point various they
sounded good maybe a little harder okay
hey very impressive so much drunk okay
okay tell me a little bit more about
your strategy because it just fell okay
I'm gonna do it maybe I'm left-handed
than this oh you're gonna okay you gonna
do a left-handed maybe Wow oh that's not
bad
it's close this is you right here maybe
I am left-handed no idea where okay
okay so we have to think of positives
here here we do I hate before
you sure yet the dart is stuck on the
board yes it's not the worst one you're
right that's all I got so did I win you
did not win okay I didn't win but I made
the board you did make the board clearly
not the best but not bad right
a - which I'm glad it's on the poor yes
I did maybe want to be a bit closer to
Center
sure yeah because it is the closed eye
bullseye how close i bullseye show do
you say eyes okay so that's everybody
but here's the thing it is too close to
call
all right I don't know if you guys can
see this but that's Troy's and that's
Taylors and they are literally the same
distance from the bullseye so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go grab two of
them and we're gonna have a sudden-death
one throw face off close eye bullseye
[Music]
it's really not Taylor you are first
okay same dart as last time yes and
don't mind that we're standing right
here
so you through with your left hand is
that what you're doing this time yeah
I'm gonna keep keep keep the left hand
going okay this is four hundred dollars
cash money alright pressure no pressure
[Music]
Taylor Oh congratulations
oh my god you won the closed eye
bullseye challenge I'm so honored there
you go four hundred dollars cash money
alright that's it for the close eye
bolts I challenged let us know how you
would handle it in the comments and also
let us know what challenge you want us
to do next and we'll see you next time
on the close eyeballs our Channel
close eye bullseye challenge